[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le débrief
des questions au gouvernement
exceptionnellement organisé ce mercredi
au lendemain du discours d'edouard
philippe devant l'assemblée nationale
pour présenter la stratégie nationale de
déconfinement une stratégie qui était au
coeur des questions au gouvernement avec
une première interrogation du président
du groupe l'est républicain damien abad
à propos de l'objectif de 700 mille
tests par semaine fixée par le
gouvernement vous continuer à prétendre
qu'il ne faut tester qu'en cas
d'apparition de cas symptomatiques
or vous le savez quand on sait que 50 %
des cas ce sont asymptomatiques et que
ce sont les asymptomatiques qui sont
responsables de 40 4% des contagions on
peut s'interroger sur cette stratégie
c'est tout simplement prendre le risque
de rater près de trois quarts des
clauses ternes et sans et d'avoir
toujours un coup de retard sur
l'épidémie toute personne déclarant des
symptômes et testé déclarent des
symptômes elle est testée
elle est positif si elle est positive
alors nous faisons exactement ce que
vient de dire le ministre deux classes
des solidarités de la santé nous allons
remonter la chaîne des contacts de cette
personne positif et nous allons donc
tester
ceux qui sont entrés en contact
rapproché avec cette personne
symptomatique ou non la vérité c'est que
nous allons donc tester beaucoup d'à
symptomatique beaucoup de symptomatique
nous considérons que pour chaque cas
nouveau set de l'ordre de 20 à 25 pour
prendre une petite marge de sécurité
monsieur le président la ban
nous avons compté jusqu'à 30 en moyenne
mais votre question m'offre la
possibilité de dire assez clairement que
si pour des choix parfois de réassurance
parfois d'affichage on sortait de cette
doctrine de tests ont commencé par
exemple à tester de façon absolument
systématique une population je ne sais
pas moi par exemple 1000 salariés d'une
entreprise
au sortir du confinement ça n'aurait sur
le plan de la santé
aucun intérêt vraiment je dis aucun
intérêt et s'ils s'étaient multipliés à
l'infini
ça rendrait impossible la politique
nationale de tests qui elle a une
logique et qui elle est la seule qui
permet de casser les chaînes de
transmission la réouverture des écoles
continuent de susciter des
interrogations la députée la france
insoumise de seine-saint-denis sabine
rubin vaut savoir si ce ne sont pas des
raisons économiques qui ont amené le
gouvernement à prendre cette décision
contre les recommandations du conseil
scientifique
la rentrée aura bien lieu le 11 mai
commençant par les plus jeunes élèves
maternelles et primaires soient ceux qui
peineront à respecter les est barrière
c'est aussi qu'ils ne peuvent se garder
seul je n'ose croire que cette décision
est motivée par la reprise de l'activité
économique
alors pourquoi retourner à l'école pour
faire quoi se demandent certains alors
qu'il ne restera qu'un peu plus d'un
mois d'école il faut aussi nous
expliquer pourquoi avoir décidé du
volontariat qui laisse les parents
devant un choix cornélien terriblement
anxiogène anxiogène en plus d'être
inégalitaire car tout le monde n'est pas
à armes égales face au choix d'emmener
son enfant ou non à l'école notre
inspiration est d'abord sociale
l'exemple le plus fort c'est évidemment
les cp ce1 de ré paieraient plus ils
sont déjà 12
donc ils répondent par nature aux
conditions sanitaires qui sont fixés
sont des groupes de moins de 15 dont ils
font partie des premiers qui rentreront
et je m'en réjouis énormément parce que
oui notre priorité c'est l'école
primaire depuis trois ans c'est très
clair et ça l'est toujours plus est dans
une période comme ça c'est là qu'ils
allaient risque aussi de décrochage très
fort de décrochage de des apprentissages
et donc nous y tenons beaucoup sur le
volontariat des des adultes comme des
élèves
je vous invite sur ce point comme sur
tous les points a résonné à contrario
c'est à dire êtes vous prête à soutenir
la thèse inverse et à la défendre
autrement dit ce que vous voulez que
nous allions chercher les élèves chez
eux et forcer les parents à les
accompagner
bien sûr que vous protestez auriez si
nous disions cela l'instruction est
obligatoire en france n'y a aucun doute
sur ce point les parents ensuite envoi
ou pas les enfants à l'école
s'il ne les envoie pas il y aura un
enseignement à distance et c'est ainsi
que nous récupérerons qu'il ait quelques
décrocheurs que nous avons encore parce
que nous serons particulièrement
attentifs à eux et nous aurons
évidemment une action pour les inciter à
venir
le gouvernement a annoncé hier que le
déconfinement progressif s'adaptera aux
réalités sanitaire des territoires mais
pour pascal brindeau député unis
agir est indépendant du loir et cher
cette approche territoriale ne va pas
assez loin
si la situation sanitaire de la nouvelle
aquitaine n'est pas celle du grand est
si les mesures à prendre sont évidemment
différentes aux sables d'olonne et à
bobigny comment comprendre que les
plages restent interdites à toute
activité quand les médiathèques peuvent
réouvrir partout en france
c'est un un combat de la nation toute
entière que cette levée progressive du
confinement avec des possibilités qui
sont conférés aux territoires demain de
pouvoir en fonction de données
d'indicateurs que nous mettons à
disposition des collectivités et des
préfets de pouvoir déterminer sa hélas
il est nécessaire d'aller un peu plus
vite un peu plus lentement de revenir un
peu en arrière
cette flexibilité qui est accordée aux
collectivités c'était une demande
renouvelée répétées de la part des
collectivités des préfectures c'est ce
que nous avons d'ailleurs fait lors du
stade 2 de la maladie de l'épidémie
lorsque un certain nombre de préfets ou
de mer ont été amenés à prendre des
mesures territorialisée qui pouvait
aller d'ailleurs jusqu'à un couvre-feu
ou la suspension d'un certain nombre de
marchés ou d'activités en journée dans
leur commune donc encore une fois cette
trame ce plan qui a été présenté qui a
été adopté par l'assemblée nationale est
maintenant à la concertation des élus
des préfets de tous les acteurs de
l'état pour qu'ils puissent vivre
il sera à nouveau présenté dans sa
version finalisée et pourra vivre
ensuite dans les territoires au fur et à
mesure que ces territoires seront amenés
à je l'espère rester en verre ou
basculer d'une zone à une autre
et justement zone rouge zone verte
quelles conséquences pour notre vie
quotidienne
c'est là qu'est ce qu'ont porté par le
député la république en marche de loire
atlantique françois de rugy
est ce que vous pourriez nous dire
quelles sont les conséquences concrètes
d'être dans un département vert pour le
déconfinement pour les entreprises
peut-être pour les établissements
scolaires écoles collèges lycées pour
l'ouverture des parcs et jardins
peut-être même des plages comment
comptez vous associez monsieur le
premier les élus locaux à ces mesures
différentes selon les territoires
un certain nombre d'obligations ou
d'interdiction pardon prévaudront
partout en france
la capacité
la nonne ouverture par exemple des cafés
et restaurants je les dis restera
valable partout en france au moins
jusqu'au 2 juin et ensuite sur un
certain nombre de choses
on peut évidemment différencier
l'application ce sera le cas s'agissant
du rythme d'ouvertures des écoles je
pense notamment au collège
ce sera le cas aussi dans la façon dont
nous aurons quand je dis nous c'est pas
le gouvernement les autorités
préfectorales les autorités de
l'éducation nationale dans les
départements et les maires dont nous
apprécierons la discussion et je crois
que c'est très important de bien le
comprendre
dans un département vers l'ouverture des
écoles primaires elle peut se passer
alors bien sûr il ya des endroits où
elle va se passer de façon un peu
différente
il faut laisser le maire être en mesure
de dire aux responsables de l'éducation
nationale dans l'école anatole-france ça
va pas être la même chose que dans
l'école jean moulin
parce que les lieux la façon de
s'organiser
le nombre d'élèves inscrits dans l école
rendent plus facile ici que là
l'organisation parfaite de cette affaire
l'important c'est que tout le monde
reprenne le chemin de l'école mais qu'on
prenne en compte la situation
particulière quand elle se présente à
l'intérieur même d'une commune quand on
sera dans une zone rouge et camer nous
dire à l'hôtel commune compte tenu de
l'explosion du nombre de cas on n'est
pas encore prêt et là on discutera avec
eux et on comprendra la spécificité de
la situation dans cette commune pour
essayer de trouver la bonne façon le bon
rythme d'ouvrir l'école dans les
départements en rouge
toutes les communes ne sont pas affectés
de la même façon et donc au fond ce que
je veux expliquer ici c'est que c'est
une logique qui commandent des effets et
qui commande
l'esprit du partenariat entre les élus
locaux et les acteurs de terrain
comment s'organisera la réouverture des
transports en commun à la fin du
confinement le député la république en
marge des bouches du rhône jean marc
fues les i à poser la question dans
l'hémicycle le premier ministre a
annoncé hier des mesures fortes pour
rétablir de façon encadrée les
déplacements cet objectif constitue un
défi majeur
pour les opérateurs de transport
monsieur le ministre comment l'état
va-t-il accompagner ces acteurs de la
mobilité pour assurer une offre de
transports publics tout en permettant la
bonne application des gestes barrières
de quelle manière des solutions
alternatives telles que le vélo peuvent
être être encouragé enfin qu'elle sera
monsieur le ministre l'offre de mobilité
réelle au 11 mai en france
vous me permettez de revenir sur les
trois piliers qui est consiste en kaki
et soutiennent notre politique de
déconfinement dans les transports
d'abord une politique qui consiste à
augmenter l'offre est donc très
prosaïquement à avoir le plus de ram
possible le plus de véhicules de
transport possibles pour y mettre un
nombre réduit de personnes ensuite
diminuer la demande diminue et la
demande pour éviter les phénomènes de
d'engorgement dans les transports
publics notamment aux heures de pointe
et cela suppose en lien avec les
entreprises de faciliter le recours
comme cela prévaut actuellement au
télétravail ou encore d'organiser
l'étalement des heures d'embauché et de
débauche dans les entreprises c'est un
travail compliqué mais qui est fait de
façon efficace par mes courriels par mes
collègues bruno le maire est émue elle
punit copie enfin protéger protéger
évidemment les opérateurs de transport
s'est fait depuis d'ailleurs le début de
cette crise un décret a été pris en ce
sens par le premier ministre protégez
évidemment les voyageurs
ça se fait au travers de l'amélioration
des procédures de nettoyage de
désinfection et évidemment par le port
obligatoire du masque qui prévaudra à
côté du 11 mai qui fera l'objet de
contrôles et le cas échéant de sanctions
voilà pour le débrief des questions au
gouvernement quasi exclusivement
consacré aux annonces d'edouard philippe
qui a présenté ce mardi la stratégie
nationale de déconfinement la semaine
prochaine les questions au gouvernement
auront lieu mardi à 15 heures on se
retrouvera pour un nouveau débrief